vietnam is among the latest countries in
southeast asia facing a new wave of
covet-19
infections the country's health minister
has said a newly discovered variant
could be responsible for the surge
vietnam has seen case numbers double in
the past month but still
has one of the lowest death rates and
the country is ramping up its defenses
to keep it that way
the discomforts of the pandemic known to
many around the world
are now common in vietnam too
authorities in ho chi minh
city are ramping up covet 19 testing
first focusing on high-risk areas
residents are on alert amid fast rising
case numbers
i'm more worried about the new virus
variant i have to wear a mask more often
and also limit meeting other people
ho chi minh city has been partially
shuttered with many businesses closed
and public gatherings restricted
some residents find themselves behind
quarantine cordons amid local outbreaks
students are vacating their dormitories
to make way for a new hospital
in preparation for the worst
the last flights to hanoi have landed
the busy international airport is
closing for a week
vietnam recently announced the discovery
of a suspected new variant
possibly merging types first seen in the
united kingdom and india
it says it will soon share test data for
confirmation
vietnam is in a race to vaccinate so far
only one percent of its population has
been inoculated
only weeks ago vietnam had achieved a
month of zero community transmissions
its strict arrival quarantine measures
and fast lockdowns proved effective
but covert 19 is finding cracks even in
the most cautious countries
and for more on this i'm joined by
michael tataski who's based
in ho chi minh city he is a journalist
hi michael good to see you
tell us more about this new variant
that's causing
a surge in cases there in vietnam
so there's still a lot we don't know
about this variant yet i mean it hasn't
been confirmed internationally yet we
don't know if it
came from outside vietnam and was just
detected here or if it
uh came about during this outbreak that
remains to be seen it also remains to be
seen exactly
what its impact is on people who have it
there were reports
um just a little while ago in domestic
media that younger people are getting
more seriously ill
um in a northern province that has seen
hundreds and hundreds of cases
uh so that that's concerning but again
we don't know what cases are linked to
this very uh
or exactly how what impact it has on
people who who have it
michael as we heard in our report
recently
vietnam had a month i think it was of
zero um community transmissions
this new outbreak must be must be a blow
yeah certainly um this isn't the first
uh wave we've had
uh since the start of the pandemic
there's been two or three other ones
more regional than this one this is
certainly the most serious um
in the entire pandemic actually um but
yeah
the daily life had by and large been
quite normal here um obviously no
no international travel but domestic
travel was normal
we could go to bars restaurants movie
theaters all of these things
that many other countries have not been
able to do for the last year
and here at ho chi minh city where you
know not all non-essential businesses
are now closed
similar in hanoi and other hot spots
with a lot of cases so certainly this
was
something of a shock to the system and
how's the vaccine rollout going
uh quite poorly so and this is probably
the least
weakest aspect of vietnam's response to
the pandemic so far so the country's
gotten
about three million uh astrazeneca doses
through government contracts and
the kovacs mechanism um but only around
one million people have
have received a shot i think the number
of fully vaccinated people is
under 50 000 out of a population of 97
million
um the government is quickly trying to
source more vaccine there are also
domestic vaccines in
um in testing phases but it looks like
it's going to be several months before
any kind of
even mildly substantial part of the
population will have access to the
vaccine
or a vaccine all right that is
journalist michael tatowski
uh reporting for us there in ho chi minh
city thank you michael
thank you